i'm tired as all hell yeah you've just
been building a [ __ ] ton of phones i've
just been building furniture for the
past week
and she's just been going through like
the entire ikea like catalog yeah i've
just been building that right pretty
much like
it's like never it's just like am i like
a respawn point for ikea photographer
because like
every time i build one another one just
respawns the next day i'm like
what's in the most satisfying build what
wait what is the most annoying furniture
to build in general i want all your boys
ikea anything not from ikea
sometimes it's good there no okay what's
like the item that is always most
annoying
uh i have my own thoughts on this i've
already decided i don't i don't know
maybe i mean i've built desks shelves
chairs tables
i built everything name it i built it
what was your answer connor since you
seemed to have it once a night okay so
bet oh [ __ ] let's get a little spill
beds can be annoying
right beds get beds can be quite
frustrating if you get the really cheap
beds of [ __ ]
they they're like they're either like a
two by two rubik's cube or a
64 by 64 gauntlet cube you know what you
know what you need to get what we got
koala beds is it a shout out
are you being sponsored by koala bears
right now no no yeah i don't know
because i will say i did sleep on uh
chris's couch and actually could we get
some tissues
yeah because chris because chris has
like the
bed right i think by them yeah and i was
like
chris's chris is chris is sofa uh sofa
is nicer than my bed
yeah because we i mean i remember when
we just moved here i just bought like
whatever was
the cheapest option on yeah biggest
mistake
and now i regret it because at that time
it's like whenever you move into a new
place the the most difficult part is
just
the amount of upfront money you put down
you look at your bank account you're
just like
oh that's a really low number and that's
a really big number i'm giving away all
at once right so do i really need
a a microwave i'm sure i can just slap
my chicken hot you know yeah
that's how i just rub it across the
ground
whatever like i'll survive yeah yeah i'm
finally getting rid of my uh
my laundry machine uh washing machine
yeah we get we're getting rid of
ourselves
yeah i got rid of my my cockroach
infested one that one oh you still have
that one
yeah i still have that one okay okay
what's been in there yeah yeah yeah it
is nice to get rid of it and get a new
one get something nice you can afford it
treatment
i'm taking the old one from this studio
are you yeah yeah
wait why are you actually yeah because
we have to get rid of it and i was like
well i'll take it
this is better than the one i have wait
are you actually taking nails yeah yeah
this is the first time hearing about it
yeah what what do you think was going to
happen with it
i thought we're just going to get rid of
it oh i was going to get rid of it well
no why would you do that i'll just take
it well no because if you go to like big
camera or like
yodabashi and you buy like a fridge from
there they have a free service where if
you have
a fridge already they'll get rid of the
old one for you yeah
so i was just gonna utilize that what to
get rid of my fridge yeah
have you so why don't why do you still
have your old fridge i thought you
bought a new one no no no no
no my washing machine washing machine oh
washing oh washing machine oh yeah okay
yeah if you buy a new fridge on amazon
there's a service that that's what i did
okay that will take the old one away
yeah
chaos i just saw ashley come in doing
like the john travolta like
we have two staff and it took both of
them five minutes to get some tissues in
the other room
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on hold on we're gonna go wait can
we go back to the whole fridge thing
okay okay so wait okay i got rid of my
fridge
by doing that service where i bought a
new one right here to get rid of it
right yeah but wait but did you say you
were gonna take alfred no i'm taking our
washing machine oh your washing machine
i thought
explain to me the logistics you were
just like
i was like i was like did this man
really just be like so yeah i'm taking
your fridge
i'm just i decided i'm taking your
fridge this is just i'm taking a a page
out of my ancestors books and just
taking things
other people's houses i thought you were
taking the fridge from the studio
no no no no no i already have it you
guys know i have a new fridge i know you
know that's why you're so
why would i get a new fridge you have to
be you have to be specific
what the [ __ ] i literally just got this
fridge it's a great fridge
okay great great average because i i
this is the first time i'm hearing about
you getting a new fridge so that's why
i'm not getting a new fridge oh my god i
already have a new fridge
i'm i'm sorry when did you buy the
fridge like four months ago
wait the coffee comes to my house the
cockroach one
yeah but i also okay remember when i
just said you see i swear to god
five minutes ago you just said i still
got the cockroach fridge i have the
laundry machine
the cockroach laundry machine i have
wait wait
laundry machine as well okay so when i
got
my fridge it was a it was a two-for-one
deal
you know
they both had cockroaches in them yeah
well no but they were they were in the
same building
you said your washing machine also had
cockroaches yeah
there might have been one or two in
there i can't remember bhutan rewind the
clip right now
i speak to someone on craigslist the
sauna fridge and a laundry machine is
that what you call it
a laundry machine right they both they
both came here in the same truck they
both came from the same place
yeah frankly if your fridge had you know
there was like a good
15 20 cockroaches in this fridge i'm not
i'm not
you know at that point i'm not giving
you the benefit of the doubt with any of
your other appliances
like how can you live with that many
[ __ ] this was vile this is
actually violent yeah i don't know i
don't understand something go go go how
big were the cockroaches because i've
i've never seen like cockroaches in
japanese in japan
there was like one or two that were
pretty big chunkers but a lot of them
were the little baby ones yeah
uh but like the worst part was and this
is very much a gross warning i never
spoken about this before but like
like when i when i ripped off all the
felt and stuff yeah there was a hole in
the felt and i
i put it in like a [ __ ] uh like
bleach stuff i know that doesn't kill
them but it's one of the bleachers the
fridge how did you kill them uh most of
them were already dead oh
okay there was so many dead cockroaches
inside of this fridge yeah it's a yikes
it's pretty disgusting
and i paid for that i paid for that
i can't believe that that's what you get
man for using what what craigslist
craigslist you know i was the one time
where i was like i'll give craigslist
a chance i'll give craigslist a chance
i'll try